most stories in the borderlands  start bloody  they end bloody too  sometimes  all it takes to change the galaxy  is a trio of losers trying to get  through a bad day  we are in the middle of a tdr invasion  leave immediately this area is now under  tedious jurisdiction they think there  was a vault key being kept on the  station if we can find whatever's in  that vault before td or does we can  change our lives  we're bad at this like really bad  tedious has many guns  talking guns guns with legs i'm gonna  blast you so freaking fat yeah  shut up richard  [Applause]  i always wanted to change the universe  for the better and now we actually can  but more importantly we'll be drowning  why are you people like this  if you happen to see any corpses along  the way uh don't worry about them  they're just uh  yeah don't worry about them